[Music]
[Applause]
luna
the fastest easiest way to buy bitcoin
if you're just getting into crypto it's
the perfect place to start
[Music]
hey guys and welcome back to the leia
highway pun show
as you can see i have a really great
guest today
previous cto of coinbase entrepreneur
angel investor
previously and um anderson horowitz it
is biologist biologist how you doing
hey how are you doing yeah i'm good
thank you before we jump in i just want
to let everybody know
that um this is powered by icon plus
capital the vc firm
also sponsored by block fi so you can
actually get up to 250
dollars when you sign up which is pretty
cool because they offer really great
interest rates
um and if you are watching on youtube
please don't forget to um subscribe hit
the like button
so you never miss a brilliant guest so
biologists welcome to the show
where are you based right now uh
undisclosed location but
i'm in asia okay okay cool
and when i was doing loads of research
um trying to figure out okay you know
what we're gonna talk about
um there's so much to discuss with you
you have so many
interesting opinions on many different
topics um
a lot of opinions which i share so
i'm gonna i figured i'd sort of just
free flow with this and kind of see
where we land
i want to go back a bit you were the
previous cto of coinbase
how did you get into this space
um so i've been interested in this kind
of stuff for a long time you know i
um i was you know i learned about uh you
know the fed and other types of stuff
from ron paul in the 2000s but
um you know i always thought that in the
fed was
idealistic but a little impractical and
then i really understood it much
more after the financial crisis and even
still you know the fed
is at it's like the center it's this hub
with
literally millions of spokes coming into
it so just in the fed
i don't think was practical but to exit
the fed and build like an alternate hub
like over here that was um that had a
bunch of connections coming into it like
what bitcoin is
that actually would be practical and so
you know
like basically when bitcoin uh you know
came out there's a lot of things that
are on one's radar
i really started paying much more
attention to it after it recovered from
the
crash in prices uh the first one like it
went up to 32 dollars in the 2011 crash
down to two
but then it recovered up and so i got
much more heavily into it around that
time
and i actually taught a stanford class
starting in late 2012
early 2013 that included bitcoin as a
component i still have some of my
lectures from that online and uh and
then of course bitcoin took off in a
huge way in 2013
and uh you know that pulled me into the
space basically full-time for
essentially the last eight years i think
a lot of venture capital and other
things on the side but let's say the
through line for the last eight years
has been cryptocurrency
and it's changed so much since then but
not just this space but the world has
changed
and you have this um sort of orwellian
kind of perception of how the world is
right now
um and i i i sort of share that to an
extent so
i just want to understand why you have
that perception what is it that's going
on in this world right now that makes
you think oh god you know
we're going down a bit of a dark path
well i i would basically say i might
slightly rephrase to say it's not so
much
that it's my perception is that the
world
is in some ways becoming morbidly not so
much that you know like i
i i desire an orbital kind of thing yes
so what's interesting is yeah so
basically i actually think it's kind of
bimodal you know that that uh
tale of two cities you know thing you
know it was the best of times it was the
worst of times
um i think what's happening is
all the futures are happening right the
extreme dystopian
cyberpunk surveillance state you know
where you know drones whiz by overhead
everything is tracked uh and you know
you have to barcode scan to enter a
store
um and you know somebody can hit a
button and pull up everything
you can be deleted from the internet i
mean you know you could have
cash that can be deleted from your
account unfortunately
all those things that i've just
described either happened or are
on pace to have okay uh you know china
is a sneak preview of some of these
things some of these things are
happening in the u.s et cetera
so that kind of total state sort of
thing is also happening
on the other hand you have extreme
points of light right we have
you know things like um you know boom
supersonic is
you know finally getting supersonic
aircraft again we have um
you know what what technology is doing
in terms of you know i'm actually a big
booster of
biomedicine such as vaccines but
artificial eyes cochlear implants to
restore
hearing the life extension stuff is
moving along um
we have lots of discoveries in
biomedicine like you know restoring
muscle
and things like that myostatin and
things i've tweeted about
um and of course there's cryptocurrency
and automating wall street and
you know replacing the fed with you know
digital gold something that they can't
print
uh and you know there's there's drones
and there's autonomous robotics there's
so many
good things happening where you have a
possible vision of a society where
we've actually eliminated a lot of
sources of scarcity that plagued us of
which the most important is
scarce life but you have both of those
things happening at the same time and
actually
peter thiel you know it's funny he had a
very prussian remark
10 years ago where you know at the time
i thought it was just kind of a
projection of his personality but
maybe it's just one of those things
where oftentimes the things that tech
people do
everybody else does 5 or 10 or 20 years
later right yeah
teal basically said i think it was 2009
that
uh the world is in a deadly race between
politics and technology
and that the the race may be very close
even down to the wire and that the
future may depend on the efforts of one
person who makes the world safer
capitalism
this was two months after satoshi
nakamoto had put up the
you know bitcoin genesis block at the
time nobody really knew how big it was
going to be perhaps other than you know
satoshi or hal finney
but you know like what peter was
thinking about was patrick friedman's
work on sea setting which is actually i
think also very important in the
fullness of time will become very
important
um is very important it's got a longer
burn but satoshi was basically that
person i think who made the world safer
capitalism
the point being you know tl why did he
talk about this
this like down to the wire kind of thing
part of it is due to his experience at
paypal where
he closed a funding round for paypal
like a few days before
the dot-com crash happened it was very
much down to the buyer
and because of that paypal is you know
like whatever
billion dollar company today it's in the
tens i haven't checked the latest
valuation
it's like a massive company today it
obviously influenced bitcoin it
influenced stripe
influenced basically every fintech
company um and it gave birth to entire
paypal mafia which was
you know reed hoffman and keith for boy
and max lovechin and all these guys
who've done
linkedin and square like just this
absolutely incredible diaspora
but it could all have died had he not
closed that round literally the day
before the thing collapsed right he just
felt something that made him push
you know and so so that model of the
world
is something which i find really
interesting and you know
as i said at the time i thought it's
just because of peter's personal
experience that he projected that
but it seems that projection is correct
and perhaps the
high upside high downside lifestyle of
the tech entrepreneur
became more common and more common still
such that that becomes basically
everybody's lifestyle and is becoming
everybody's lifestyle today
with all the pros and cons of that go
ahead
yeah i mean so you i want to go back a
second because you mentioned
china and you sort of said that this
orwellian state hasn't fully arrived but
you feel it could be coming
we could be going down that direction
and you do speak a lot about being this
freedom maximalist freedom of speech you
don't necessarily call yourself a
bitcoin maximalist but it's freedom
maximalism um so
in terms of what you feel is coming here
what would you
say is because i know you said that it's
we're sort of seeing them
a mirror of it of what could be in china
whether it's you know policing of speech
um you know policing of um
i guess you're sort of saying that we we
see this a bit in the cryptocurrency
community
as well like this vocism
policing of what you can and can't say
yeah so so on that basically um
i think it's not just uh i think in many
ways unfortunately i tweeted about this
a while ago but i think it's even more
evidence today in many ways actually
um ccp and nyt are on a convergence
right why do i say mit because they're
the ones who were kind of pushing for a
lot of the stuff in the us government
and actually a lot of
major tech companies are downstream of
them and so i kind of think of a
triangle as
you know uh communist capital
woke capital crypto capital like these
are three points on this triangle
and you know so communist capital is ccp
it's very simple it is
you must submit okay total state
been before the communist party and then
you can go and make money
not too much nowadays make too much
you'll get on the radar so that actually
that ceiling is descending quickly
right um but that's basically their
social contract right
they don't have the concept of like
quote limited government or even the
rhetoric around it that is there
west it's basically marxist-leninist you
know uh
they're like uh agent smith from the
matrix right a chair
can turn into a communist party guy if
they wanted to right like you can be
interrogated for violent
law right or what they've decided as a
law so long as you don't contest their
power it's actually extremely
straightforward then
you know you can basically just go about
your life you know make money you know
have family whatever right
that's their social contract i'm saying
it's good obviously if you're a weaker
that's not the social contract
but that's essentially how like you know
the let's say you're
your defender or even your neutral
person the regime would tend to express
it okay
now world capital is another poll
and world capital is you must sympathize
and the difference is with the the ccp
they say
um that they are powerful and therefore
that's why you must submit
with world capital it says something
different says you are powerful
because you are white because you are
male because you are straight
because you are cis because you made
some money or because you're x or y or z
some immutable
characteristic or some hard to change
characters because of that
characteristic
you are powerful and therefore you must
apologize
and what's interesting is both the ccp
and the bulk you know like like even
though they come at it from very
different points
they end with downcast office right like
you know ccp is you must submit cash
your eyes down
volt capital says you're powerful so you
must apologize again
cast your idea so both fundamentally
ideolog ideologies of submission
um though the world version of it is
much more subtle
right it's not that subtle but it's more
responsible right uh it's it's not that
subtle today
but i think articulating in this way is
it's fundamentally something where you
can
throw out somebody to get them to bend
right bend their head okay
now the third pole is and by the way
will capital i don't think of it as
fundamentally driven by the state per se
it's really driven by legacy you know
media corporations i've argued
especially nyt
as a primary expense of this paul graham
actually retweeted something
you know a few years ago tweeted out
which you can probably find on twitter
if you do
from colon paul g space hypothesis
and uh you know he shows that um
a bunch of woke words just kind of rose
vertically actually i'm not sure if you
can
project this uh on screen here we go i
found it oh i don't know if i can
unless i don't think you can okay words
like
is it words like i don't know um
hypothesis although some newspapers can
survive and switch to online
subscriptions none can do it and remain
a politically neutral
newspaper of record you have to pick a
side to get people to subscribe
and the thing is if you look at this you
basically see all these words and
phrases that we've
used before just going completely
vertical and it has controls also
it has things like china or amazon where
you'd sort of expect them to be on an
exponential or general motors it's kind
of coming down
right but you know like uh like white
privilege just
totally vertical right white national
park
i'm just going to say some words so
people know because they won't be able
to see it so you've got misogyny sexist
patriarchy mansplaining toxic
masculinity male privilege feminism
women empowerment racism institutional
racism transphobia homophobia
islamophobia hate speech hurtful
offensive triggering
traumatizing all of the ongoing that we
have these days
all the stuff and the thing is that
basically what that coincides with
is 2013 which is you know my uh
my friend arm saved had a very trenching
observation
which is uh racism wasn't a new problem
but the new york times declining stock
price in 2012
was like if you go and look at their
stock price okay
that's the thing you look at their stock
price and around that time
the washington post had been sold for
basically fire sale prices to business
right
it looked like media was down on one
knee uh you know tech had taken all this
revenue from them there's a great
uh chart if you google tech media you
know print disruption
essentially print dropped from like
about 67 billion in revenue to like 18
billion revenue over four years after
the financial crisis
and google and facebook and the iphone
all went vertical like this
and that's why you know bezos could buy
the washington post this
great crown jewel not with the not with
amazon.com but out of his own pocket
right petty cash he had 250 to spend on
this thing right
so this was like a humiliating moment
guys like jack schaefer were calling on
salzburger for example the salzburger
family johns of times
to sell the new york times right and in
this moment
you know what they basically did uh
whether you know
did i put it all on them no you know
there's there's aspects of this sort of
bubbling on tumblr and you know gawker
and you know something awful and you
know there's also
a political campaign waged in 2012 that
pushed a bunch of these buttons in order
to
i think get out the vote right so all
those things were there
but what happened was just like a
restaurant owner
might spike their food with sugar and
salt large portions
which um make them more profit
and you have a short-term engagement
with the store because you're eating
more it's tastier etc
long-term however the externalizing the
healthcare cost the diabetes or
the the heart disease or what have you
onto you right like the
the eater in the same way what happened
in 2013 is they started spiking
the media diet your information diet
with these
nerve jangling words and phrases that
just agitate right they polarize
and they get hate clicks on both sides
and uh and you know what
like if it bleeds it leads if it enrages
it engages
now i want to be clear that certainly
tech is not
not to blame for this the social media
environment also was set up for this
basically when two people punch each
other out on
twitter over some news story who profits
linksy media corporations and social
media companies right
they get i don't know 10 bucks and
clicks for two people like stabbing each
other's reputation online it's like a
boxing promoter has two people
knock each other's you know brains out
and they make money right
and so so essentially what has happened
is over the last
eight years legacy media and social
media have literally made
billions of dollars while they like rent
society to shreds
and all the social trust has gone down
right so this is basically now
and then into that place when trust is
low the total state steps in right
so that's kind of both nyt itself and
world capital but let me come back to
this triangle right
so with um you know the world capital
poll what's interesting is
despite claiming some huge rhetorical
difference you know from china
there's a lot of convergence of the two
you know i tweeted this like i think two
or three years ago
um let me see if i can find this uh
let's see
some weird ways about you know china
yeah here we are
neither side wants to admit it but uh
the us and china are converging in some
weird ways
internet censorship nationalism and
socialism state takeover of tech
companies
social credit versus cancel culture
human flesh search
and twitter mobs right so just to define
some of those things you know everyone's
like oh my god it's so dystopian the
chinese have the social credit system
canceled culture is just a decentralized
version of the same thing that's one way
of thinking about it right
and you know when uh with real
consequences people get banned from
platforms or de-platformed and just so
happens that all the companies do it at
the same time
right so china is centralized censorship
by the state it's like overt and in your
face right
in in the in the in the us because of
the first amendment what has evolved is
a totally different system
uh that's very substantively similar
namely decentralized censorship by tech
companies
okay and uh you know the third poll
which i'll get to
is decentralized censorship resistance
by bitcoin encrypted protocols okay
but another thing i mentioned human
flesh search and twitter mobs
so human flesh search is a concept in
china which is basically like a twitter
mob hunting for somebody
online to find that they said something
awful right now the exact
moral things you can get canceled for in
china are very different than in the us
like in china it's something related to
taiwan in the us
it's you know it was saying like latinx
or something stupid like this you know
which
yeah actually hispanic people don't say
it you know yeah um
and uh so it so differs or if you're not
saying latinx
um it differs but the substance is
similar
okay should i get to the third pole
cryptocurrency yeah yeah yeah
all right so just jump in any time
because i i will i will go
okay all right no okay fine i'll jump in
after the third pole gone
okay great so the third fold just to
recap we have
um ccp we have let me do it so this is a
mirror okay it's all mirror image
uh we have ccp right we have ccp
we have nyt and then we have btc okay
those are like the three poles
right communist capital will capital
cryptocapital if communist capital says
um you must submit and vote capital says
you must sympathize cryptocapital says
you must be sovereign
okay so the other two tell you that you
have to bow your head
this actually says you have to hold up
your chin okay now there's a lot of good
in this
right there's a lot of obligation in
this you have to hold your own private
keys
you have to you know like basically
think for yourself when it comes to for
example food rather than eating
carbohydrates
you have to realize actually the things
that society advises you to do like
take out the you know 30-year mortgage
or you know be in debt for the rest of
your life in student loans
the debt is actually pretty bad in
general and that you should prefer
equity and saving money to getting this
debt that
uh you know things like um you know the
food pyramid as i mentioned like these
things are wrong
and uh it's a lot of good to this right
the issue is it even that can be taken
to an extreme because
if you you know if you're if everybody
has to be sovereign for everything at
all times
there is no uh there's no collective
action there's no
shared goods there's no community of any
kind in extremis for example
um you know people actually just as a
thought experiment if
there was no ability whatsoever to
regulate food and drugs
you would have to basically bring your
own portable dipstick into starbucks
to kind of poke it into the coffee to
make sure that there wasn't some
you know bad thing in there right that
sounds like a caricature but this is
actually why
people in china for example often buy
food
from the west because they don't
actually trust like chinese baby formula
you know after some scandals like
melamine and so on there right
so that might that might sound like a
caricature and certainly relative to
you know america's fda you know we could
we could do something better with better
type one and type two you know rates but
in practice what people actually want is
a
quote regulated marketplace in the sense
of an actor that gives
star ratings of you know actors and it
bans
bad actors what's my point basically
um the form of that regulator doesn't
necessarily have to be a nation-state
regulator
it can be an internationalist capitalist
regulator in a sense
ebay for example is a regulator of the
marketplace they give star ratings and
ban bad actors right
um paypal has fraud reviews amazon has
reviews of books and they ban bad actors
uh you know uber and airbnb do the same
thing these are
cloud regulators internationalist
capitalist regulators not nation
state-based regulators
which achieve some of the same functions
and they do so in a competitive
marketplace
where exit is the overall governor if
you don't like uber's regulation you go
to lyft
right if you don't like airbnb's
regulation there's other kind of you
know
services that you can use point being
that uh the extremists of you must be
sovereign
basically takes no regulation
to the point of denying that people
actually want
some kind of third party quality control
right they want to contract somebody to
do it
they don't necessarily want to do it
themselves um but denying that that even
exists can be one failure
another feeling mode is on things like
covet right where
um one of the things that's really
difficult that i find is
unless you're a scientist right and you
know i have a background in
genomics and bioinformatics and what
have you so i felt
well equipped to go and read the primary
literature read things with a grain of
salt
diligent things say that's a bad paper
that's a good paper that's really
interesting this maps what i know
but i have a lot of sympathy for people
who you know i don't know let's say
let's say this was um
earthquake geophysics okay that would be
an area where i know
you know enough physics you know physics
of waves and so on to probably get into
it
but would i be able to you know really
get in there right away and look at the
data
not at the same level right not as it
not as much as environment
experience so i'm very sympathetic to
people who are caught between either
zero trust or total trust right and most
people can't have like
intermediate levels of trust in
something their trust is either broken
or it's
or it's present you know and so what
happened with the government
is when they went and um i mean with the
u.s government
western governments when all this
official misinformation came out masks
don't work before they do
cova's contained and now it's there
everybody has to stay at home but you
can go out to protest
but you have to see hello but the
governor doesn't have to
people can see the inconsistencies on
this and so i'm sympathetic to those
people who just now distrust the state
but that's a failure mode of you must be
sovereign because
we're just social animals we can't all
figure it out for ourselves so what i
think about
is what i call the decentralized center
okay so in these
kind of three poles of this triangle
right prc
nyt btc you want the decentralized
center
where it is you know it's not exactly
moderates because it's going to be quite
different from like the moderate world
of
you know 1990 or 1980 it's a different
kind of center
but it's something which is like you you
have a society that takes
the the people who were exiled from each
of these three kind of quadrants
right the people jack ma right who in
china you're not just jack ma but all
the hundred thousand whatever
entrepreneurs and
crypto chinese who exist by the way
there's not just communications the
script of chinese people who are much
like you and i
with similar morales they just live in
china right so we shouldn't just think
of it all being bad people there's a lot
of
you know a lot of very good people there
right i mean it's obvious point but
some of the rhetoric around it i think
says the chinese doing this the chinese
doing that i think it's
important to send your ccp from your
average chinese person many of whom are
very cosmopolitan and positive some so
so something you want something which is
appealing to them
you want something that's appealing to
people who are tolerant
but not book and you want people
something that's appealing to people who
are
libertarian but not you know in favor of
crypto anarchy right
now why do i say that right crypto
anarchy is cool but i prefer crypto
civilization
okay crypto anarchy you know what that
is yeah yeah yeah
okay so crypto energy for your viewers
and by the way again jump in because
i'll just go
okay okay we actually i'm going to go
back then half a second though because i
don't
go too far just yet just pause on the
crypto anarchy i just want to focus on
okay i just want to focus on the whole
idea of this
woke culture just for a second um
because it's not so obvious to some
people and for me whenever i'm looking
online and i'm reading twitter and i see
tweets
like yours um people who share similar
ideas it's always really refreshing and
i don't understand why um because you
said it's a bit more subtle
um compared to the ccp which isn't so
subtle
for me it's the same thing it's just
different right like it's communism
and it's exactly the same thing and it's
what's coming over here to the west
but it's done with this whole um you
know you must admit because
um you know you're privileged and it's
not fair and we've got to help and we've
got to be kind it's come
come from a more moral standpoint so my
question is
why isn't it so obvious because you kind
of brush past this as if it's so obvious
as if you know
yeah we can easily compare this to the
ccp and what's happening there but it's
not so obvious to some people
even in the crypto community it's not so
obvious people wearing masks and things
like that in like profile pictures
and and all these things you know like
there's a lot of signaling going on and
it's not always so obvious to people so
why would you say that that it is a bad
thing okay
great question so first
one thing i would observe so actually
david shore was a pretty smart guy on
the
you know democrat side you know i
wouldn't consider myself to have any
political labels but
uh he i was able to actually note
something after the election that most
people wouldn't be able to know
which is actually um the democrats
actually gained in the
white vote and uh republicans actually
gained on the minority side right which
okay well so that's contrary to a lot of
the narrative or what have you
and uh what what i think is interesting
about this
is i think we're starting to see
something which is sort of like
um the
like these extremely woke white people
who are expecting
sins real or imagined for you know
inheriting money or something like that
like a lot of these people are like
choked and and exert whatever grads
and you find that it is the privileged
whites who call out quote other people's
white privilege the most right the
privileged
concern with other people's privilege
and this is a weird form of expediting
their own guilt because they know that
they inherited something they didn't
found it
but the way they execute that guilt is
conveniently by tearing down other
people
right by tearing down you know some poor
southern guy or some
guy in the west or you know some some
plumber in new york as being
white privileged as if they actually
were you know going to exeter and church
and
and so on and so forth right um so
that's one aspect of it
the second aspect is uh that you know
people like
you know yourself or myself who have
some intersectional credential
right like you know being non-white or a
woman or what have you right and
actually that's a vast majority of the
world
if you think about it only something
like depending on how you count less
than twenty percent of the world is
white i don't know the exact percent
it's not like 80
is quote people of color right and then
you add women and so almost everybody
has like some intersectional credential
okay yeah and uh
because of that we can sort of
we have like some shield or armor in
this stupid social media game right
the third thing as to why this thing is
popular is um did you have a concept of
immune escape for viruses
no okay so a virus can be targeted by
like a develop vaccine mutation that
lets it wiggle out of that
yeah okay so you know essentially it
mutates and now it's
escaped your immune system or it's
escaped the vaccine okay this is
actually something
about the other day so if you think of
communism and localism is my viruses
okay basically i think it's actually
this is actually a very deep concept i'm
going to go deep on this for a second
right but
if you think of those mind viruses yes
localism has structural similarities to
communism
okay uh but there's some fundamental
differences that have led immune escape
if you think about it the much of the
world was vaccinated against communism
over the course of the 20th century
at the cost of 100 million dead you know
if you read you know seven countries
okay that's interesting so you're saying
we're we're vaccinated against communism
oh i see where you're going with this i
see where you're going with this okay
partially right but the thing is rocasim
versus communism
so communism was a redistribution of
wealth vocalism is a redistribution of
status
right communism was offensively for
workers and peasants
vocalism is ostensibly for women and
minorities like yourself and myself
right communism was about the union
strike and wokeness is about the woke
mob
communism setting was a factory floor
and wokeness's setting
is social media and so the thing is why
do communism spread if you actually go
back and look at it i mean this thing
started with a book and it grew to
control an enormous swath of the earth's
you know surface right the ussr china
cuba like
this thing did appeal to people it did
quote
win against you know more practical
philosophies why is that the case right
and part of the reason is it's not the
only reason there's several reasons
part of that is the microeconomic
incentives for communism okay so that's
to say
if you were uh like do you know how that
is
no okay so from this book up to
sinclair's book the jungle right if you
go and read that book
you'll get a sense of what attracted
people to communism these guys
were working in factories they were
going to this wrenching transition of
the industrial revolution
uh they were alienated from their farms
and their homes
you know sometimes children were being
worked really hard there were disasters
like the triangle shirtwaist factory
and so so much a program was heaped on
the unethical owner who had all this
leverage and could
you know bankrupt you or you know put
you out of work and you know the the
family farm that you wanted that was now
being
bankrupted by these big factories that
you know or big you know
industrial operations you just couldn't
you couldn't make it as a family farm
anymore right
um all those were real things and so
uh you know the what happened was some
guy came into
uh a factory and they basically say
we've got the answer it's communism and
here's why you gotta do you gotta do
you build a union and do strikes and
then what do you do everybody here
will get some money why because you'll
make that boss
bend that boss who's so powerful all of
us together are strong you know
and we'll make him bend and now we all
get raises whoa oh my god the strike
worked holy cow
and that would get reported in all the
communist papers and everybody would
you know like you know raise their fist
oh we did it and then the hangover the
next day or the next week or something
happened because
you'd have union dues right that would
actually be coming out of your paycheck
that was increased now it's decreased
you have a second boss which is like the
union manager on top of the other
manager right
you suddenly have speech and thought
controls so elia kazan had this movie on
this in the
mid 20th century called on the
waterfront you ever heard of it no
okay worth watching simply to get a
sense of that time and place
where basically you'd be canceled for
totally different things but essentially
being
disloyal to the union or you know which
could expand into lots of things like
being
working a little too hard you know and
trying to make us look bad
you know all of those kinds of things
right you can start to see how that
would be
cause for cancellation and you'd lose
status among the other workers
and so the combination all these things
meant that your factory
your company became less competitive
over time but what you're basically
doing with the strike
is debiting from the future um to build
the president now with that said strike
is a pressure tactic
what the workers the communist workers
thought was happening at that time
they thought it was a zero-sum situation
where the boss
would would lose and they would win it
turned out to have to be a negative some
situation
where they were actually harming both
parties over the long term
including themselves by making the
company less competitive
but they didn't understand that because
they could only see it was a negative
some situation
with a short-term positive gain it's
like getting in a very high interest
rate credit card kind of thing
you get the money today it sort of
tricks the psyche right okay
yeah so that's like part of the
microeconomics of it the other aspect of
course is the religious zeal you know
nietzsche wrote in the leading kindreds
god is dead and what he was observing
was he wasn't actually
invading against god in that particular
uh you know epistle
he was basically saying you know there's
enough educated people who don't believe
that um there's going to be wars beyond
imagining people are going to look to
fill
effectively that god-shaped hole and
what a lot of people did is they filled
their worship of god with gov right with
the government
right the government can do everything
right there's an ad a while back which
was
government is the thing we all belong to
right and
so essentially people project onto it
this monotheistic thing of
the all father right the everything you
know yeah
and and so they basically they're quote
secular but they actually believe in
this thing as green lantern because it's
like the most powerful thing
right they literally worship you know
the government right so there's a second
aspect in the
vacuum of god people projected all this
power onto this thing okay
so these are some of the reasons
communism spread now let's bring it to
lopez right
wokeness um has done immune escape it
doesn't look exactly the same
so for one thing basically i don't know
the hard hat right was 1971
no i'm saying no to everything my god
what is that
so the hard hat right is 1970 actually
so that was actually the flip
okay basically for essentially about 17
something actually around 100 years
the the working man and his noble nature
that was
essentially like the backbone of
communist you know revolutions all
across the world right
yeah yeah but in 1970 an important flip
happened where
union workers in the us came out to
beat up the hippies who were protesting
against the vietnam war
which meant that union workers had
basically been cut in
to american prosperity enough that they
didn't feel alienated
like the guys from 50 years ago right
this by the way you know rather than the
the win-lose situation or the negative
some situation the win-win situation is
exploitative boss right the negative
some situation really lose lose uh
is is a union strike the win-win
is actually aligned capitalism right so
the way to meet communism in the past
the way that actually worked was aligned
capitalism where
to avoid this negative some situation
where you
as a ceo or the executive are harmed and
your workers are harmed even if the
strike organizers don't get it
you cut them in on the pot this all
should eventually lead to startups
and equity shares and so on and so forth
where you're not seeing
that you are aligned you're proving it
by giving them a slice right i'll come
back to this point
but basically that was actually i think
the solution now this is actually
working well enough
now let me also give an asterisk because
i know some people are going to say
that was working well until 1971 we got
off the gold standard then workers were
no longer given such a cut
i agree i'll come back to that but let's
just say take it back to 1970 okay
so 1970 these uh the hard hat riot
these guys uh the the union guys went
out and beat up the hippies
and many people realized wait a second
the host
for the mind virus is no longer these
white working class guys
so now they were like considered the
most noble thing in the freaking world
for basically 70 years right uh more
than that like 100 something years that
like every all the bloodshed
everything was for them the working man
and so on and so forth right
and and all the faults were airbrushed
now we suddenly saw a mirror image
where this guy who is super noble became
archie bunker
and all his negative traits were
stressed the racism the sexism the
homophobia these are caricatures that
you know like probably some troops just
there's
probably some truth to the the you know
the working man being oppressed by those
boss in some way
but these aspects now were stressed and
it was flipped and so the person who is
to put the hero
of the communist revolution became the
villain
of oldness and the my virus switched
hosts
to now right so that's actually a very
important thing right if you think about
how
how much essentially the modern you know
like works beat up on the white working
class as being
benighted and you know conservative and
so on and so forth
that's a really important thing and you
know so in that flip
other things happen as well the
oppressed class theory
switched from you know economics and you
know workers and peasants
to women and minorities right the now
with wokeness now studying wilderness
for a second why does it spread how
how does something so irrational spread
well now we go to social media rather
than the factory floor
the microeconomic incentives for
wokeness are very simple
if you say that somebody is mansplaining
or
you know something like this so much i
hate that time
i know because it basically is something
which essentially delegitimizes
on the order of 50 of the world because
of their immutable characteristics but
it's not that though it's not that it's
not that like really
cruel makes my skin cruel it's kind of
just like the hypocrisy of it
because like it's still an offensive
word like
to say that like if somebody said you're
lazy splaining i would be like oh i'm
doing what like it just
it's it's it's it's it's ironic it's
hypocritical
because you're saying that he's being
sexist by using a sexist term
but the thing with with it spreading
which which
which you know we can get to i think it
was yuri besmanov who said that
you will people will never know what's
arrived
so you and i know probably most of
people listening and watching know
but i think he says you won't know
what's arrived until
you have physical harm inflicted on you
that's what he said so
if we take like covert for an example i
don't really i don't at this point i
don't really care what's happening
you know like i don't really care
whether it's real it's not real whether
the numbers have been inflated
whether masks work or not i don't care
at this point it's been 18 months and i
just think we should all have our
freedom back
um but this is for me a
prime example of what's happening and
even now
despite so in the uk our news it goes
back and forward
how many died how many haven't died it's
very contradictory
the data and everything even the rules
across the world are contradictory where
masters inside don't wear masks inside
wear them outside don't wear them
outside
so even now given everything that's
happened with our civil liberties being
taken away
people still are really blind to what's
happening and he says your resume
says until you are you actually have
pain inflicted on you
it's kind of like walking to um walking
to
i don't like to use this term but like
walking to the like the gas chambers
blind basically
it's not until you're sort of there that
you'll really be able to see what's
happening
um i don't know if you do do you have an
opinion on that do you think you know as
this is spreading
people aren't going to wake up until you
know communism really hits
so a couple of thoughts on this so
basically um yeah
it obviously doesn't have to be
something as severe as you know the
holocaust but it could just basically be
a breakthrough your window actually you
know with the with um
on the on the total reverse of that like
some of the anti-israel stuff recently
has gotten
extreme and that was a shift that wasn't
obvious until this recent event where
people were you know smashing windows
and stuff
and hitting people in the street um a
couple of thoughts on this
so first on covet you know in general my
stance on covet is i would say the asian
stance
where it just hasn't been politicized in
the same way it has in the west
and the response in general has been
much more competent like if you look at
a world map
of you know deaths and so on from covet
for the most part
asia especially east asia you know like
has has done
quite well and i would include actually
australia and new zealand in this
now what we'll come to is people say oh
well they're islands well the uk is also
an island
something about the pacific rim and the
cultural influence there
meant that people just kind of took this
as a public health thing and then they
didn't lie to
the citizens about masks don't work
before they do and all the stuff you
know that that's there
but they also validate the citizens
trust by keeping the thing under control
you know and so if you ask for the ball
you've got a dunking right
if you ask for the trust you actually
have to validate the trust and for the
most part pacific rim governments
actually did better
now the reason i say that is i think of
that as a third position
which is something which is not i think
the silly politicized
thing that's happened in the west i'm
sympathetic to your view i'm also
similar to the view of somebody who's
had somebody die from covenants who
thinks
it is very serious it's like a fractal
kind of thing where there's
enormous variability in outcomes per
person there's
you know like this is something which
root causing the noise is actually quite
difficult
part of that is probably due to um
immunogenomics let's say some people
simply have more susceptibility than
others
right part is due to things like
diabetes or being overweight part of
this due to
which variant you get all this type of
stuff what that results in though is a
highly stochastic environment where
people have
different micro environments of what
information they receive and what
they've seen on covet what tracks their
personal experience
and so i'm completely sympathetic by the
way to the idea that this has
been used by western governments to
erode freedoms
um i also think that you know this is
something that
has killed whatever millions of people
around the world so it's like a real
virus
and it's a base that could get more
serious that's to say like started out
pretty bad and could get worse
now the problem is that that kind of
position is i would argue like a
rational position
but people want to bucket you into one
or two camps in the west because that's
where most people are
reasonably so right so that's kind of my
position on covid
um it is uh
it's something which i think is like um
you know
most people weren't prepared for 10
years of iraq most people aren't
prepared for 10 years of covet
the bad thing about it is going to be
all the surveillance stuff that we've
got when i say 10 years ago what i mean
i say there's a possibility not a
probability but a possibility
that uh there if you're if you're
looking at some of the work i'm looking
at that there's immune escape
you know like essentially efficacy
versus vaccines coming down
um the flu has a totally different you
know uh
architecture at the genetic level it
won't be super technical but has a
different architecture which makes it
more immutable
however it looks like covet is managing
to do some immune escape
there's websites like next train and so
on the track what's that likely to
result in
probably booster shots every x number of
months that of course won't be taken by
people
um and uh so so i you know
it's just something where there'll be a
fracturing of society on this
i think that over time the the one
good thing that comes out of this uh
that i'm seeing
is sort of a y-shaped recovery where
there's much more investment in
fitness tracking in home gyms in
personal health
in glucose meters and all that type of
stuff because i think that's the thing
that people
can agree on which is i want to track my
own health i don't want i don't trust
the cdc or the fda or the uk equivalent
sarah
right go ahead yeah you say that but you
know you're talking about people
actually wanting to take personal
responsibility over their health
and um home gyms and all that but i just
disagree
i think we're moving down a path of
laziness where nobody wants to take
responsibility for anything
of course people do but i'm i'm just
generalizing um
you know i think in in america they were
sort of saying we'll give you a free
donut if you come take a vaccine i mean
like
this is a public health thing i didn't
see that
yeah yeah yeah it's just like open the
damn gyms like go
okay go say if you go to the gym and you
do a good workout we'll you can have the
vaccine you know i'm just
it it to me to me it's all just very
strange and i think we are moving down
this
um i wouldn't say dystopian future
or this dystopian path because i do
agree with you that there is
a lot of plus sides to things especially
with technology and cryptocurrency
and i think that one of the questions
somebody actually asked was
um ask biologists what he thinks some of
the um
key skills people need um to survive the
next two decades because like you said
i do think covered will be a decade
situation like let's just say brexit as
an example as a british person
that went on for four or five years um
this is this is going to be a decade
thing i don't think it's going to be
as difficult as the last 18 months have
been but it's
a lot of the stuff isn't going to go um
so how do we
from an entrepreneur's standpoint how do
we survive the next
20 years because jobs that people are
doing now
will become majorly redundant for many
different reasons
whether it's tech or whether it's
covered whatever it is that's right so
basically like
you know what is my ideal right my ideal
is
a um you know so to caricature right
this is a caricature but uh the democrat
wants more government the republican
wants less government
uh the libertarian wants no government
and
the technologist wants a new government
right how to start a new country how to
start new states you know
and so uh the reason i think about this
is i think that
what we're in the middle of is
essentially the unbundling and
rebundling of legacy nation states
um if you know if you think if you think
2020 was lit
you know i think the 2020s are going to
be liter okay
so to speak um and what i mean by that
is
uh the shocks of the system you know the
you know like 9 11 attacks the 2008 you
know financial crisis
2020 you know corona and so on these
are you know like essentially like a
larger
and larger and larger ruptures right
that they do die down you know in the
sense of like like resources are thrown
at them they die down
but a new normal is attained right the
new normal of surveillance
the new normal like you know post 9 11
obviously way more surveillance
post 2008 all of these like you know
financial regulations and so on
in place post 2020 right much stuff but
also a new level of resistance to that
you know yeah and um so so it's like
pushing in both sides of
high centralization and decentralization
and
um so i think this is like the story of
the century
that fight between centralization and
decentralization i think that
um you know you ask what should your
viewers or whatever do so for those who
can i would say learn computer science
and statistics
and i really mean that okay why because
those are general
okay general cells like just what
physics was
to the early 20th century of course
physics is still valuable you should
learn physics it's great
okay um however what's interesting is
think about okay let me ask you a
question what percentage of your time do
you spend looking at a screen
too much too much let's say 80 i don't
know 80 percent it's terrible it's
really bad okay
so here's the thing most of the rest of
your life will be spent in the matrix
okay okay meaning like most of your
waking hours
are being spent in an artificial virtual
constructed world
it's on a screen today it'll be in vr or
ar
glasses or something like that tomorrow
that's where the economy is going
that's where all of these things are
going you know have you tried
oculus quest 2 no okay it's worth trying
because it's actually really good
like let's say you know it's actually
immersive in a really interesting way
you forget that you're in physical space
you need a dime like that for example
shiv is thinking about it fine so
there's also ar glasses that just give
an overlay on the world so you still
know where you are
right um and there'll be other kinds of
things like this
one are you thinking about it is um
when are you born 1990 something like
that uh
a little earlier yes yes let's say
something in the 90s probably okay it's
okay i'm a 90s baby yeah
fine fine okay so you know at that time
each day
you could count how many communications
electronic communications you initiated
and most of the time it was zero right
like we remember a time before the
internet
now today you cannot count how many
electronic communications you've
initiated
because you know like the number of
packets we're sending back and forth
here
if you have a fitbit if you have this
you get that you're just constantly
sending these
electron communications and you know
this is also going to be happening with
transactions like the number of
electronic transactions you're sending
your economic complexity is rising um
oops i'm still i'm still here yeah it's
just my camera
okay yeah so so essentially like
the the virtual world that we all live
in is
just like building up like virtual
girders building around
and um people are going to spend way
more time there for several reasons
first the devices are improving okay yes
um we're going to a world where physical
is a premium product
or maybe are arguably already there what
i mean by that is in the 1990s you know
there's this concept of digital divide
you remember that
no i was a baby in the 1990s okay all
right
so 1990s essentially the idea was um
you know some people aren't online
there's a digital divide they're not
advantageous
now today we actually are starting in
western countries you know like
like basically countries that have
internet penetration we're trying see
the physical divide
where um it's cheap to put you know
millions of transistors
you know on on a chip but it's expensive
to put thousands of people in a room
right physical is becoming expensive
physical is becoming a premium product
for several different things okay number
one for example plant travel
zoom is much faster than the you know
like basically anything that you do you
do digital first right
communication are you writing a physical
letter you're writing a message
every single thing that you can think of
if you can do digital first is cheap
because it's just electrons weren't
right okay number one number two is ai
is coming online in a really big way
so sam altman who's you know my
colleague actually tweeted something
like this that he thinks a lot of things
jobs that are done on the screen the
price of them is going to deflate
drop very fast faster than actually
offline things like plumbing and so on
until robotics gets good
that will cause some weird things i was
coming in from a third direction which
is
in the event that inflation happened so
i was coming out from the crypto rather
than the eye direction
in the event that inflation happens it
will disproportionately hit physical
things you know my arguments
why can you can you guess it it will it
will disproportionately hit physical
things why
because lumber or you know oil
or food those are physical goods and
scarce but the marginal cost of
serving you another file from dropbox is
not that much
so it might you know going from point
zero zero zero zero one cents even
10xing that
is not really that noticeable if the
marginal costs are low
right so as the world outside becomes
more and more and more expensive and
the digital world becomes cheaper thanks
to ai
and uh you know because everybody's got
these phones and so on
you have something where physical
becomes a premium product and more and
more
life is spent basically in the matrix
now i recognize there's lots of bad
stuff about that world okay
um however uh and i think that we can
use that world
to break out into a better physical
world or come back to that point
however in the intervening period of
like
digital first physical as a premium
product um
you want to learn computer science and
stats because that's how you shape
what's on screen
computer science is the algorithms and
data structures and stats is how you do
calculations on those data structures
cisco analysis thereof
any anything you know tesco i know
that's a big shock in the
big business in the uk you go into tesco
you know cs and stats they can point you
to the database you can add value
you want to go to boeing you can add
value you go to pfizer you can add value
everybody has algorithms and data
structures and so that's a way a lens of
looking at the world that's going to
give dividends for many years to come
yeah so just on that point where you say
that um you know everybody needs to
start um
learning the new technical way computer
science and everything like that it
makes me laugh
just because it reminds me of that meme
where people say learn to code
right there
and it is a meme and it is funny because
not everybody can learn to code and this
is
wait let me jump in on that so okay so
learn computer science and statistics or
learn to add value to somebody who can
okay but how do you how do you add value
when all your look like the man that's
70. how does he even men that are
i say men women as well sorry whatever
but even even
people that are in their 40s now
or higher you know if they haven't grown
up with
this new world of technology or
aren't necessarily in one one you know
paying an interest in it when they were
much younger
it's very difficult to make that shift
let's take truck drivers as an example
right
20 years ago you're a truck driver yes
you still had access to
um you still had access to the internet
and social media and
all this stuff but it wasn't really that
hot um
and you know you're not really going to
start learning to code at
40 50. you're just not especially 60
onwards so
what does that mean for a large portion
of society and i think it's andrew yang
who's really big on this he talks about
um
universal basic income because it's not
fair to
some people that we are moving into this
futuristic
um future if you like um
so what do we do because not everybody
can actually learn computer science and
things like that
i'm naughty i'm not even techie i've
been able to find value in what i do
which is great
i'm not techy i just have an interest in
i'm just interested in freedom to be
honest and i like to speak
so i've done fine but what if other
people can't do that
then what okay so several things the
first is um
it's a multi-pronged answer uh so first
they're you know i'm investing in things
like lambda school
there's also mavens other things like
this that actually are showing traction
on retraining
um and they do so by basically just they
take like a walmart clerk
who has enough persistence and they
train them to become an engineer okay
but how old are you talking though
in their 30s right so you know i
actually i don't know i
i'm not i don't want to speak out of
turn i actually do not know the age
distribution of the people there right
but i do know that they've actually had
significant success with folks who are
outside of traditional
venues because um you know one of the
things they're doing is like objective
based learning where they just keep
they're like you will learn how to do
this and they just keep doing it over
and over
until people get they debugged it over a
lot of folks that's lame school there's
others
okay but some of the retraining stuff is
starting to work uh
and and so i think that that's actually
an important piece number one
basically if you think about it with
computers we should be able to do
education much better
you can track all kinds of inputs and
outputs you can see whether someone's
getting problem right and what their
stimulus was
so it's plausible that insofar as the
brain itself's computer that we can
track io and apply
that computer science and systems to
figure out how to do the i o better okay
you're basically installing software let
me come back to that by the way let me
bookmark
and sort and software in the brain um so
one is i'm not
totally giving up on returning number
two is ben harvest's point which is
the jobs of the future are harder to
predict because
like we know what the jobs of the
president are we don't know the jobs of
the future are
if you think about it like you know the
industrial revolution transition
everybody bemoaned
the transition from the farm to the
manufacturing floor
now whatever 100 you know like about 100
years later
people bemoan the fact that
manufacturing jobs are going away
right okay so what do i think you know
if the 1800s was farming
and the 1900s is manufacturing what is
the 2000s
i actually think it's both totally
obvious and not obvious
which is the 2000 this century is about
investing
let me explain what i mean by that
that's to say everybody becomes an
investor
just like the the you know social media
turned everybody into a publisher
cryptocurrency is going to turn
everybody into an investor this is
already happening
um why because okay maybe you agree
right so great so
it's robin hood it's coinbase it's
venture capital it's angel investment
it is you know the the um i've seen like
everything that you can do the
blockchain is defy it's all of the stuff
right
and uh with you know concretely what
that means is a larger and larger
percentage of people's income is going
to come from capital gains
if you could plot that i think that's
going to start rising okay
um and you know there's an interesting
flip sometime by mid-century
maybe sooner maybe later where the 99
percent
are capital and the one percent are
labor what i mean by that
is so that's a flip of the 20th century
in the 20th century you thought of
like the investors being rich and you
know the worker is being poor
right capital where the one percent and
labor is 99
in this century it may flip where
everybody's an investor
but there's a tiny percentage of
founders who are able
to take capital which is flowing like
water on this internet
and turn it into a useful product this
by the way i think is one of the
least appreciated things lots of people
think that if you have money
it's just click your fingers and you can
build a spaceship right
you click your fingers electric car
right or even you know like a genetic
test
or or dropbox right it's not that easy
uh if you've ever done capital
allocation of any kind
like actually running a business
starting business or anything it's just
not something you can't buy
a spaceship off the shelf right it's
people think that
because something is easy is easy or
looks easy that it was easy to build and
it's not at all right that interface the
api if
put in a dollar put in a pound get back
you know like a
pencil as that famous story goes you
know like it's really hard to
create a pencil right you know what i'm
talking about from yeah yeah yeah yeah
like the lead and the pencil and the
eraser yeah i know everywhere and
everyone does every part and yeah
exactly and the api is very simple which
is putting the money but the thing is
actually ridiculously complicated okay
so
so i think that um everybody becomes an
investor
you just have to click a button online
on robinhood on republic.com
on angellist on you know this or that
app
to invest nowadays so it's similar to
the experience of amazon
but it's very different because you know
it's in the game you're tracking it
right
and there's huge downsides you know if
you think about for all the ceos or
whatever
you know watching this like and a lot of
ceos have had like bad board members or
something
think about the worst board member
you've ever had one one a thousand
experts is a retail investor right
they're the most short-term flighty they
don't even know what the heck is going
on most of the time i'm synthetic to
them of course
but we need to build structures that
accommodate this 10 100 000 x increase
and one of those things is going to be
provable on chain alignment so people
aren't quite scamming people or doing
short-term things you want long-term
holding
you want like a thousand different
on-chain assertions um
basically that decentralized regulation
uh that kind of
i shouldn't say replaces the ssc but
becomes the exit to it right
an alternative that other countries can
adopt you know just like you could exit
the fed right okay
so that's the second part of it
everybody becomes an investor
that is something that everybody can do
um
but you know it is quote gambling like
in the sense that you may or may not
achieve a good outcome all right what's
the third thing
um so first is retraining second is
everybody becomes an investor and so
it's a multi-part thing i'm not seeing
any one of these okay
the third is there are new jobs arising
okay um
you know you're an influencer i'm not
sure if you're a professional influencer
but that's basically what you know i'm
one might call you right something like
20 of america wants to grow up to be
youtube stars the reason that actually
might be not as insane as people think
is
there is an enormous amount of time
spent looking at screens our entire
consumption pattern has shifted content
is a larger larger percentage of the day
it has increased x so the market for
content is increased people are paying
you know online for this content now
which they've learned 20 years ago
so content creation is a third thing
which people can do and why is that
important because
if you know one of my sayings is code
scripts machines
media scripts humans okay number three
number four robotics this is actually
coming online in a big way
so if you look at vicarious.com if you
look at boston dynamics
the robotic future is happening now we
need to push this farther faster
okay why because on the other side of
the robotic transition
you have the hyper deflation of prices
due to the fact that lots of things can
now be made by basically
uh electricity right you charge the
robot what you want to do
the intervening thing will be very
destructive as lots of people are put
out of work
but it's like the industrial revolution
transition you want to catch them with
some other things
okay um so i mentioned retraining i
mentioned everybody becomes an investor
i mentioned uh robotic automation was
number three what did i say
um number three uh you said retraining
everybody becomes an investor robotics
what was the fourth one uh there's
another one that i just mentioned i
forget about come back to um well
content creation
right oh content creation yeah yeah yeah
and you know the thing is
that and then number five is uh this is
actually a big one very good one
um the the new blue collar you know
i don't really like this framing of it
but i'll use it because i don't have
something better yet
the new white collar blue collar is like
above the api below the api have you
heard this concept before
no i'm waiting to hear what you're going
to say if you're an uber engineer you're
coding the api
and if you're an uber driver the api is
telling you right
yeah this is like you know some people
frame this as incredibly dystopian and
bad
i actually don't think it's that
different from a factory manager
and an assembly line worker if you
romanticize manufacturing jobs
the api application is just like a
decentralized factory floor
right it's like a bunch of people are
being given direction by manager but
it's in the form of code
and it scales a little better it's a
little more you know um
predictable and so there's bad aspects
obviously you know
the algorithm can can you know lower
your prices or search you or whatever in
other ways
but so long as there's competition and
that's what we should want we should
want competitive businesses
lyft we should want tesla's taxi
services that comes up then
you have an equilibrium hopefully that
is reasonable so that's potentially a
huge
catchment for a number of blue-collar
workers yes
the factory worker may not become an
engineer but they certainly probably can
become an uber driver
or something like that right okay so
that's five right
six is the unknown the unknown is like a
very large category because
predicting the future in detail is not
obvious if you told people
you know in in 1980 that you know
like computer engineer would be the most
popular job in
you know 2020 like computers just
weren't that popular right a lot at the
time
you know steve jobs was marketing
computers like that early apple
mac and stuff around that time yeah yeah
yeah
it was so limited in memory that he was
talking about using it for like storing
recipes
okay now and because you could do
computation with it you could store
recipes the
internet connectivity wasn't there games
really weren't that impressive
and there's some stuff it was okay but
you really had to believe in this
computer thing
right to think that it would be such a
large potential economy you have to have
some vision right
so six what kinds of things do i think
arise in the future
okay drone repairmen okay robotics
all the servicing of all the stuff will
be a big thing okay
lots of stuff related by medicine for
example general phlebotomist
a phlebotomist somebody no i mean some
sort of chemist of some sort right
well it's somebody who takes your blood
right okay
yeah so mobile phlebotomy i think is
going to become a really big thing
why because people can get blood tests
on the go everywhere right and that's
way more convenient basically
you're going to the doctor and have them
take blood and do tests
yeah okay you get like these kind of
data points
right the problem is often those data
points are like extremely episodic
and really what you want is like a
continuous measurement just like your
graph from your um
your website clicks or something like
that you just want whatsapp you wanted
over time right
so mobile phlebotomy and that's just one
like sort of blue collar job within
health um
you know hospice care as people age
there's going to be more of that
um everything related to uh you know
babies and elderly people i think will
surge because
that's the stuff that you kind of want
care you don't want a robot to do it
right
and so you think that will be human
that'll be human interaction
that's gonna be human uh i think for a
while until you can have an extremely
emotive robot that's very hard to do
uh and all the homeschooling push
homeschool has increased in search in a
big way because
there's these vogue schools they're shut
down you know teaching like all the
stuff
so people are going to home schools
because it's better education and
whatnot
and then they're realizing actually that
you can separate out at least for those
kids beyond a certain age
you can separate out the babysitting
component of school
right from the education component
school and you factor those out into
essentially
somebody who is watching the kids and
then like the
super advanced like learning apps that
they're doing you know
so it's almost like they're supervising
their work on the learning apps
so that's a relatively low skill you
know job that people can do yeah i don't
i'm saying nothing is bad but it's not
requiring computer science
you know how to punch some buttons on an
app make sure the kids don't hurt each
other
and you can be like the kind of back to
the future the the one room schoolhouse
you know
the one room schoolhouse for like you
know 10 people right okay that's another
job that i think is going to
surge let's call it it's not exactly
homeschooling by the way it's like
community schooling or community school
teacher or something like that right
yeah
um crowdfunding community schools each
other if you have a name for this yet
maybe we do maybe i haven't paid
attention
but something like that okay other
things
um biomedicine in general i think is
gonna soar and
all the things associated with that um
i think uh you know like the entire
crypto supply chain of course is is
coming
and you know that that's uh that's many
things um a lot of it is skilled of
course
uh but you you've got the investing
stuff that i mentioned you'll have
people
also who are doing data and putting data
online like weather reporting and so on
for crypto oracles so that people can
quote make bets on uh like you know the
uh whether their field is going to get
rained on
more of the future jobs i can project
some of them based on things like drones
like robotics
crypto like bio um space is actually
becoming bigger
you know so space mechanic that's
becoming bigger and bigger like people
are able to launch satellites
um so a lot of the future that we were
promised is coming um
electric car repairman blah blah blah
all those kinds of things
construction i actually think we're
going to have a huge build out in the
middle of america
in remote areas uh because people will
have houses in the middle of nowhere
because they want to kind of get away
from people
and have kind of intentional communities
so i think that that's going to be a big
area so that's physical or at least
supervising robots okay
and so on and so forth i think you know
can i pre which ones of these are going
to be absolutely massive
hard to say okay uh i do think that um
like you know bio are pretty bullish on
but one of the things that's hard is
sometimes
jobs like elevator operator you know
they were really big and they're really
small and we don't really think of them
as jobs they're really kind of
you know small things or like taking
care of horses that was a huge thing
not a big thing anymore you know um so
so that's
some of the things i think that people
will do i know that was a long answer
but i'll
yeah right so um
oh last thing number seven uh the hyper
deflation of cost if you remote work
okay so for anybody who can remote work
or anybody who can move
can actually do really well in this
environment because they can arbitrage
the entire world right they can go to
the place
the most suits them so even if physical
prices are rising they can bring those
costs down
by using essentially a geographical
search engine to find the best place for
themselves to live and work
so these are different ways that you can
kind of adapt to this coming world
um it's an incomplete list you can
probably sort yourself into those
categories maybe afterwards i'll look at
the transcript and kind of sort it a
little bit more
but those are some of my thoughts go
ahead yeah firstly
wow that was very very thought through
um
really really really fascinating really
interesting um
i think that i really thought the whole
idea of everybody becoming an investor
is absolutely spot
on um you know i've got friends who
aren't interested
in finance or anything like that and
suddenly you know now england's out of
lockdown
kind of um like we meet up and
everybody's sort of buying this
everyone's buying that and
it's really shocking and you also make
an interesting point because when i was
younger everybody wanted to grow up and
be
a singer a dancer or a footballer now
everybody wants to be
a content creator and an influencer
major asterisk on the everyone wants to
be an investor things super super
important
which is at the beginning of you know
the weimar hyperinflation
everybody thought they were getting rich
you know mark was up all this prince of
money was out there
there's so-called you know cantaloupe
where like people get that early on
everybody thinks of becoming
millionaires
and new fortunes were created but the
only people who retained those fortunes
were people who put some or a big chunk
of it into gold or other hard currency
remark right so i think that actually
this economy i actually do think um
there's essentially two drivers right
one is the state printing all this money
which is going to cause at some point
like significant inflation it's already
starting
um and so that will cause you know
bitcoin to rise
so i definitely advise people who are
concerned about inflation buy bitcoin
bitcoin do not sell bitcoin hold your
bitcoin
right uh and if you can learn how to
hold your bitcoin locally and auto
exchanges but even if you can only buy
on exchanges
you know uh do that right um yeah
so that's one and then number two is i
actually do think that we are moving
into this digital first world so i think
that
tech will continue to do well in a
fundamental way
but i think that folks who are not
sophisticated investors
or who are not holding btc could very
much lose their shirts
in this environment which will make
people mad okay
um so i'm definitely not saying go out
and gamble your money or anything like
that if you only buy one thing by
bitcoin
um and uh you know bookmark this okay
if you're a sophisticated person you can
potentially be better than that but
that's like the no op
you know yeah the golden one
yeah no i'm gonna say go on go go go go
on
the no op basically means the action you
take in the absence of
it's basically a computer instructions
that says don't do anything right buy
bitcoin hold a bitcoin
and that's kind of your insurance policy
and just you
just hold it you don't like you don't
touch it you don't look at the price
every day
uh you go about your life because it's
whatever percentage of your net worth
that you can essentially write it off
right but it's your insurance policy
um and uh so that will cause
in some way some disillusionment with
everybody becomes an investor and will
polarize people against it
but i think it will also um kind of lead
to that world because
bitcoin holders are investors in a sense
right they make a projection of the
future
there's something else but i wanted to
return to which actually your point
about yuri bessemenov and how
it's only sensed when there's a physical
actuation right okay
so um in software we are able to
determine whether bits have been
installed
on a machine right if you go and you
right-click an app
uh you will see the signature and the
certificate which shows who developed it
you know what website it came from you
can probably if you want to figure out
who the ceo that was and who the
software developers were
and you know if it's open source even
you can go back and find the lines of
code that are running on your computer
right you can
you can track origin okay and
as consequence of this is partly a
consequence we can do things like track
download stats
we can track internet traffic we can see
bittorrent and we can see
you know like smtp and these various
protocols on the web
you can track website popularity ebb and
flow you can track all of these things
okay
but we are not as good at tracking we're
getting better at it but
we're not as good at tracking is the not
the
code that is installed on hard drives
but the ideas that are installed in
minds
okay so the thing is that um
i'm trying to give a okay here's a good
example abolish the please
okay that snippet right those three
words
uh you've heard it yeah great okay
that's actually like
software that there was a slogan that
was developed
by somebody and optimized uh it could be
effectively an emergent thing where you
know somebody said it and then other
people modified it and so on
or it could be literally like a call to
arms actually a better example which we
know
was developed was um occupy wall street
and you know the 99
right there's actually an article on you
know how they came up with the
propaganda poster this is like eight or
nine years ago some of your viewers may
not remember it but
um i think there's ad busters in canada
that came up with that here to occupy
wall street and the means and so on and
so forth and they push it out there
right
and then millions of people are talking
about the 99 of what percent that
polarization that frame
that was effectively advertising
marketing collateral that was built by
smart people in conference rooms right
or
whatever it was the ad buster's office
is right and
so that's code that is executing in your
brain where you don't have
an origin for it right you it's not like
software it's not digitally signed
you don't know where it came from right
uh most people aren't even thinking
about the fact that it came from
somebody in fact
to see that it came for somebody is
considered conspiracy theory paranoia
whatever
however with twitter you can actually
root cause and if you're good at twitter
search you can find who like the first
person to say something was
right okay search.twitter.com you can do
basically look for keywords you can find
out like
when does this meme originate right like
it's a digital thing where you can trace
it back memetic archaeology
just like we trace back the origins of
covid or well that's a hard one because
china's
yeah i was gonna say yeah but let's say
a virus in general
you can one that's not political and
controversial you can
trace it back to where it came from
right you could trace back individual
genes
figure out where they they came from
right we can do the same with memes we
can trace them back
now one issue is that twitter makes this
challenging because it's a corporate
database
not everybody has access to the
so-called historical power search api
in fact very few people do uh that's an
arcane api which you need enterprise
access to and twitter's permission
to look at all the tweets ever okay if
you could look at all the tweets ever
you could determine and when and who
spread certain means
that eventually took over the world
right who are the initial promoters of
it
and so on and so forth you can actually
start getting ideological root cause
for at least anything that was spread on
unencrypted social media now this is
what i'm interested in like
decentralized social media
um there's several platforms out there
but the key is that these
things now have blockchains where you
can print out
every single equivalent of a tweet
anybody can do so
and so now you can actually audit this
and you can see the diffusion of memes
and we can sort of
audit our information environment see
who's putting it out there
and like who are the initial circulators
and you know
what conflict of interest they have or
whatever right um and you put basically
an origin stamp on that right i'm not
saying necessarily to attract
attack the person sometimes the meme is
good or harmless or whatever right
but i am saying to understand you know
did it come from the wet market
or did it come from a lab or did it come
from you know some
like zoonotic leap these are interesting
things to know right
okay going a little bit further you know
if you think about the history of
genetics
right mendel uh you know came up
phenomenologically
with the fact that uh you know like the
pea plants and the crosses like
you know big a little a if you remember
that from you know high school
genetics he came up with some of the
laws you know mendel's laws of genetics
which are not full cost but they apply
for you know straight dominant recessive
characters from the dealing traits
but he didn't know how that actually
worked biochemically he just observed at
a high level phenomenologically
okay and uh you know
fischer and some of the other early
genesis had a different model for
so-called quantitative traits like
height right and they had a model where
you know it would um it would be like
more like a bell curve rather than the
zero one of mendelian genetics
it fell to later scientists to determine
okay the structure of dna in this sort
of so-called neo-darwinian synthesis
which is the molecular biology of the
gene that's to say how
the gene could give rise to both the
individual mendelian characteristics
as well as collectively to things like
okay why am i talking about this
because what remains to be done is for
us to figure out what the
molecular neurology of the meme is okay
these memes float around
how are they stored how are they
accessed how are they represented
how are they deleted how are we
vaccinated against them we have only
really the faintest understanding of
this stuff
we're starting to get better at it with
things like neurolink but some of the
work by
you know guys like nicholas going back
20 years
on brain machine interface um you know
some of the work on the so-called i
think the jennifer aniston neuron
you know where specific memories or
associations of things appear to be
stored in like particular neurons like
the jennifer aniston neuron famously
with light up
not just when you heard about jennifer
anderson but you heard about friends
you know because she was on that show
right and we're also seeing things in
artificial neural networks that seem to
have similar characteristics
which seem to recognize like the the
concept of an eight
you know like not just the number eight
but it's spelled out eight
um you know it's like eight dots and so
on and so forth we're starting to see
these kinds of things
artificial neural networks it's like
you've got a brain of that you can kind
of poke and trigger and see this stuff
right
once we understand better the molecular
neurology of the mean how means are
stored and represented
once we understand better how to audit
social networks and decentralized media
um i think we'll understand better how
to both promote and vaccinate against
you know bad means like vocalism like
communism we'll actually understand
how to deal with media corporations that
are spiking the equivalent of sugar
into every story putting you know the
patriarchy or whatever into every
headline in order to sell copies
um one way of doing that for example is
to have chrome plugins
that are decentralized where you can
view all the code but that auto read an
article for you
and then highlight in red all the
trigger words that are meant to get you
angry
and that like auto substitute right it's
literally remember my thing about the
food taster
and the the it's like that
for the untrusted environment media
you're like oh this guy
actually spiked it with 15 rage words
that i might not have been aware of
unless i had seen these nutrition facts
on the side which this
tap gives us right go ahead no
that's interesting um that was a lot of
a lot of information
um
no it was really really interesting um
just to think that we could
move to a world where we have those
those trigger words
um and people can sort of decide for
themselves you know whether they want to
go forward and indulge and you know
whether it
is likely to purposely um either be
political or aggravate you or whatever
it is but these decentralized apps and i
know that you're really interested in
these things like bitcloud and whatever
but i'm not gonna go into it because
time and everything but just on a last
point i know that decentralization um
is obviously the goal for a lot of
people is for me to some extent
um but i i'm often quite skeptical about
the
um how successful they will be right so
like people don't like youtube for
example because
censorship twitter because of censorship
and all this stuff that we've spoken
about
um of course you have competitors or
equivalents we have like uh
lbry library which is supposed to sort
of be the decentralized version
um you know you've got a bit clout which
is getting a lot of wonderful facebook
um
again you're knowledgeable about the
space lbry you know
is good i'm an investor in that like you
know you know a lot of the technologies
i'm impressed
i know i've seen your show before but
you have more you like you know some of
the more obscure things which i i think
a lot of people in crypto don't even
know about now
not to beat up an lvry for watching i
think it's actually quite good but it
hasn't yet been widely used but i think
it's actually
it's starting to get traction as a
decentralized youtube um but i still
think but
what i'm saying is i think that a lot of
the time the user experience is really
unfriendly
um i don't really love youtube but i'm
on it just because i have to be on it
this show is live on youtube it's not
going to be on lbry
um library um you know we have parlour
which isn't decentralized
but it was supposed to be the competitor
and that obviously had issues
so i'm just wondering you know whether
we really will be able to get to a place
um whereby we have decentralized
applications
um which brings the power back to the
people you know
it takes away any um concerns about
censorship
um again i'm not gonna get into it
because of time but i also think you
know what happened donald trump was
awful
um so in terms of the user experience do
you really think we're gonna get to a
place where everybody finally migrates
uh short answer yes but let me give a
slightly longer answer
um so first is uh you know in tech
stuff doesn't work until it does just
wins like vertically right
you know ethereum like had like fits and
starts and then just went totally
vertical
d5 was hopefully kind of flat and went
vertical in 2020 when people figured it
out
defy summer happened um you know virtual
reality was
flat for a long time lots of fits and
starts and then oculus was just this
huge
leap forward um you know people tried
web band in the early 2000s and the tech
wasn't there and then 20 years later
instacart is massive
right um you know things like cosmo for
delivering things in the early 2000s
uh late 90s that also was infeasible but
then once you had 100 billion
build out of mobile phones and so on the
capital infrastructure was there
and then you could have instant delivery
or everything and so on and so forth
there's lots of you know ai you know
we've been working on it for 50 years
things people thought were easy turned
out to be hard things people thought
were hard some in some cases turned out
to be easier than we thought
chess turned out to be easier than
driving a car for example though most
people wouldn't think of it that way
this is like more of x paradox i don't
know if you're aware of this but
logical reasoning is relatively easy for
a computer what's hard is sensor motor
stuff
like balancing driving and things like
that that requires massive computation
so the the thing about it the thing
about software in particular is
when it works it can just go whoosh
totally vertical
same thing that's a sensor or an
actuator the robotic stuff that's harder
because it's harder it's harder to
iterate on the cycles are slower
in that software in the decentralized
software when it works it will take off
with no warning
beyond just following the space every
you know like like really closely and
being like okay they figured it out
you figure out how to scale block chains
like actually if you look at polygon or
bsc you know scalability is now
happening on you know both ethereum and
ethereum like chains
with some compromises yes but you know
you've got solana you've got avalanche
you've got your protocol you've got
polka dot you've got all these guys who
are working on this
so uh that scalability then allows
people to do
more sophisticated things a lot of
cryptography by the way that's involved
with that
let me actually make a few comments on
that just for a second okay just as a
plausibility thing
for those of your audience who know
about error correcting codes if you send
n bits um and there might be an error in
them
the obvious thing to do is just resend
that message over and over again and
hope that
you can kind of do best of three and be
like okay there's a bit flip here and
there
it turns out that mathematics you can
actually do more like log base two of n
so if there's eight bits you don't have
to send it twice thrice you don't send
16 24 bits
you can just send another three bits
like essentially the error correction
code bit
why those three bits are functions of
the other eight uh and it turns out
there's corruption you can detect it and
you can ask for a resend only if there's
a corruption
and so with advanced math you can
achieve more
compression than people might otherwise
think a lot of the recent stuff with
like loop ring and zk roll ups and so on
uses advanced cryptography
zero knowledge proofs and things you
know that are allied to achieve
compression
and to actually get on you know on chain
scalability now
does the average joe need to understand
this no no no more than they
understand furry transforms to pick up
their phone okay but
the math is there the math is coming so
i'm actually
bullish on the space in the long run let
me just say one other thing
which is um the
with all of that said i think
decentralization is a tool but
centralization is also a tool
the goal is to achieve good outcomes
decentralization basically allows us to
pull away our trust from institutions
that try to make it obligatory
i don't have to trust the us dollar
right i don't have to trust
you know a wall street regulator i can
go to another country with a different
regulator
i don't have to trust you know twitter
or facebook if you can have
decentralized media right
basically though and this is a critical
thing you know i think it's a mistake to
say
it means trust no one it means you have
a choice of good trust
right civilization doesn't mean an
absence of leaders but an abundance of
them
and so i think what will happen is given
a choice people will
re-centralize around better leaders
it's not just getting back to the same
place though it's more like a corkscrew
where there's aspects of it they're the
same place
but hopefully we're moving up along the
z-axis towards better leadership and so
on over time
that's how i think about you know the
unbundling and rebundling
the decentralization recentralization
decentralization that's just a cycle
that happens in computing
it happens in history it happens in
technology um
and i think it's also happening here
with nations and with states and so on
yeah i certainly don't think it's going
to be one or the other and i even think
the
rise of cbdc's which we haven't spoken
about but another time
um i definitely think that the rise of
cbdc's definitely sort of shows that
because you have the option of well
eventually we'll have the option of
bitcoin i don't think that's ever likely
to be banned
um successfully um and then you have
cbdc so
you know the existence of
decentralization versus centralization i
think will definitely exist
um but just finally it's been so
fascinating hearing all this i knew
when i was putting questions together
and topics i was like i knew
we would talk about a range of different
things um
so just finally what are you working on
right now and how can people
follow your work and get involved
great question so i've got a site
1729.com
where um we're putting out like a
newsletter for
um tasks and tutorials so learn crypto
earn crypto also
burn calories we have a proof of workout
thing um
this will relate to something i've been
thinking about which is um
content that is aligned with the viewer
so
as to say you read the content and you
actually have demonstrable approval
gains
in either your portfolio or your
learning
or your you know your weight or your
muscle mass or something like that
and you're starting to be aligned with
the reader so you're not optimizing page
views you're optimizing
the improvement in the reader's
lifestyle which has now become feasible
because you know we have fitbit we have
uh you know like crypto and so on and so
forth like
what would men's health be in the era of
fitbit what would
bloomberg look like if all the news and
content was scored against your
portfolio performance over time right
so this is a thing i'm thinking a lot
about like what a healthy positive sum
content environment looks like and you
know if you define the metrics
often you can define the entire product
because that's what you're actually
optimizing
so that's the kind of thing that's on my
mind right now and i'm also writing a
book so go and subscribe to
centralground.com
it's free put it out there you'll you'll
hear you know apology stuff if you want
more
yeah i think that's really interesting
being able to essentially just provide
content
directly for the individual it's not
about the survival of
whoever's providing it like you know
what would bloomberg look like if it was
aligned with people's portfolio it's an
interesting thought to be honest um
but biologists i want to thank you so
much it's been so so interesting
um like i said i knew that we would have
so much to talk about so
it's been absolutely brilliant um thank
you so much for coming on and thank you
everyone for watching
thank you okay speak to you soon take
care bye
[Music]
uh